foreign
the entire purpose of a scientific
journal
is
to figure out what is scientific and
meritorious enough to broadcast right
to the extent that some person outside
of that world wondered
I mean effectively this is the so-called
yeah you can't folks you can't blame
Paisley for trying you can't blame
Paisley for trying to gain access to one
of the Premier science journals on Earth
and the fact is paisley he I guess has
done us a service by
revealing that that journal is uh
non-compass mentis right that that is a
legitimate service in fact is that the
service that Paisley was hoping to do
but okay I don't know maybe Paisley's
gonna reveal Paisley's self to be uh a
hoaxer who wanted to prove that the
journal Nature had fallen apart but but
the point is I don't think you can blame
Paisley for this I think you blame
nature for this no I I also put the
blame on the academics like Paisley who
have been driving Academia into the sea
for many decades now and you know the
fact that the bio uh reveals this person
as a professor of political science and
women's and gender studies
uh and has just written sex is a sex
does governing transgender identity now
this person is a political activist
masquerading as a scholar and now
masquerading as someone who knows
something about science and I I
absolutely 100 blame Paisley Cara but as
for why we are being exposed to Paisley
Cara's ideas uh this could have been
beneath the radar for longer if nature
hadn't decided to widely publicize uh
this uh this insane
anti-scientific rhetoric that is
masquerading as science well I don't
know I mean I do think this is actually
an interesting question
you have universities that will not
defend their faculty against
activists who are actively anti-science
right yeah there's something out of uh
University of Maine this week I think
uh some some some Professor insists that
there are two Sexes and one person in
the class went along with it and
everyone else had a fit and is now
demanding demanding that the professor
of resign apologize Etc and there's some
Choice quote from someone who you know
saying that this is terrible and she's
traumatized and oh by the way she wants
to be a high school science teacher I
think but I have that right I think
where I come out on this is
you have to have standards to run an
institution if your institution
surrenders its standards
you know it's a little bit like leaving
the yogurt
open on the counter for a week right
I don't think it's the first that's what
that's that's what's happened to the
universities that's what's happened to
the universities they they have become
rotten because they have not
refrigerated the perishable but no
Paisley Cara is not akin to a fungus
here because the fungus pre-exists the
leaving the yogurt open on the counter
and is looking for the niche but the
niche already does exist it just may not
exist in that abundance but this leaving
the yogurt open on the counter thing
with universities has helped create the
Paisley Cross of the world of course so
it's not it's it's not
I think actually the analogy works very
well because of course the yogurt that
you left out on the counter Heather uh
that's spoiled also created fungus which
put out spores which made the next
yogurt spoil did you say the yogurt
created fungus well the yogurt provides
a resource in which the fungus grows
which makes the presence of fungal
spores that much more common which is
very much like the universities
but the fungus pre separately exists and
I would argue you know there's a reason
that while trans people have existed in
tiny numbers in some cultures across
time
there was a reason that we now see this
thing and people you know direct
cosplaying as the opposite sex and and
making just a mess of so much of Science
and law and University and such and it
is not because they existed all the time
and they were just looking for the right
Niche that Niche that University Niche
helped to create them I agree but and
you know of course we're not really
talking about trans people we're talking
about trans activists who have taken
over the universities and the point is
yes there's something a little bit
different than the biological case in
the sense that the fungi that attacked
the yogurt are very long-standing in
some sense but there's nothing unique
about the idea that the yogurt provides
a different environment than whatever it
is the fungus rode into the house on and
that it will adapt to the phone if you
keep leaving yogurt out it will become
very well adapted to gaining access and
exploiting yogurt and that is that is
what happened to the university the
university did not guard itself against
terrible anti-scientific
anti-enlightenment ideas those ideas
flourished and experimented there and
they have now proliferated out into
society where they're looking for all
kinds of things Beyond yogurt that they
can spoil
I mean I just think it's almost it's
almost it's a Perfect Analogy in my
opinion and the point really is just as
I don't blame a mosquito for sucking my
blood right I might blame somebody for
leaving the door open if that's how it
got into the house or something but I
don't blame the mosquito the mosquito is
simply doing what mosquitoes do people
gaming systems is what people do and it
is the obligation of the people who are
stewarding those systems to protect them
from this nonsense yes but unlike unlike
a mosquito which cannot receive
education and be taught to eat something
else how do you know a human being who
truly believes that they are preaching
in science when they are preaching
anti-science and actually doing damage
to not just a lot of people but a lot of
functional systems is at base a human
being who can unlearn the garbage that
was facilitated by the university system
okay I I agree with you I'm not look my
expectation is this person who has gamed
this system
probably their intent on
they are at least deaf to the damage
that is done by what they're up to right
they're putting us all in danger by
doing this but I guess what what I'm
really getting at is
if you have a government you should
absolutely expect people to try to
corrupt it right to the extent that you
just assume that away and you leave it
vulnerable to corruption it will be
corrupted and I don't necessarily expect
the people buying influence
uh to you know rain themselves in never
that's not how it works you leave yogurt
on the counter it's going to spoil you
leave your government open to being
corrupted it will be bought and
purchased by people who you know see the
opportunity early
right if you have a university that is
supposed to be studying truth and you
leave it open to threats from powerful
political groups they will take over the
truth apparatus you have a journal that
is supposed to uh limit uh itself to
only high quality ideas in circulation
and you know you haven't provided a
mechanism whereby it will turn down
political fads then it will be taken
over by political feds so
I guess the point is I these are
entities filling niches and I don't I
think the point is the game is always
won or Lost based on whether or not you
left the niche open if the niche is left
open expect it to be inhabited it may be
inhabited by this person or that person
it may be inhabited by this fungus or
that fungus but the real story is you
left the niche open not something
inhabited that neck
I think they're both the story
and um
at the
how do we change this and how do we
create systems that ensure that they
don't get gamed what you're talking
about is the plate is the only place to
focus we don't focus on the perpetrators
of you know the people who are making
bank whatever that might mean on
um gaming the current system that
doesn't mean that they don't have agency
and don't have Consciousness and
couldn't actually be be better human
beings if they were trying yeah okay I
think we've now arrived at it the real
point is there's only one game in town
from the point of view of preventing
this sort of thing however it doesn't
relieve anyone of responsibility for uh
yeah being bad and externalizing harm on
others or exploiting uh illegitimate
niches
foreign
[Music]